as halloween 2017 fast approaches so
does the highly anticipated second
season of stranger things
man raw stuffers addictive blend of
Steven Spielberg and Stephen King the
Netflix thriller became the unexpected
hit of 2016 and propelled its young cast
members to levels of Fame they couldn't
have dreamed of when they answered that
first casting call but what are the kids
of Hawkins Indiana like away from the
cameras this is what the cast of
stranger things looks like in real life
Millie Bobby Brown Brown was born in
Spain to English parents and spent her
childhood between the UK and the US
before winning the part of psychokinetic
runaway 11 Brown had made a few minor TV
appearances though stranger things was
her first major gig is your mom here
good dad last breather as the breakout
star of the show she quickly booked a
part in universals Godzilla sequel king
of the monsters set for release in 2019
while stranger things season 2 details
remain scarce the first promotional
images released confirmed that the AYGO
loving eleven will no longer be sporting
her laboratory buzz cut instead rocking
some very 80s curls fin wolfhard
in his role as Mike wheeler fit wolfhard
took center stage alongside his
mysterious houseguest 11 showcasing an
impressive range for such a young actor
impressive enough to land him a part in
the upcoming 80 set adaptation of
Stephen King horror classic it wow she
looks great
good
pretty good in real life the
curly-haired Canadian is an indie music
aficionado who plays guitar and even has
his own band Gaytan matter at so even
though he had stage experience Gaytan
matarazzo had only a single screen
credit to his name when he auditioned
for the part of the lovable Dustin
Henderson and stranger things where are
you going you just said stick to the
plan I am I'm just gonna go get some
chocolate pudding I'm telling you a
lunch lady Phillips cord deck what his
lack of screen time wasn't for lack of
trying the new jersey born actor suffers
from a mild case of kalida cranial
dysplasia a condition where you're born
without a collarbone which affects skull
growth and teeth matter at so used his
post stranger things fame to raise
awareness of the condition and receive
countless letters of support after he
revealed that his disability stopped him
from getting parts for a number of years
but the duffer brothers wrote his
condition in giving his character dust
in the same condition and even allowing
bullies to use it as ammunition in the
show
Caleb mcLaughlin like madder at so Caleb
McLaughlin began his career as an actor
on the stage playing the young version
of Simba in the Broadway production of
The Lion King from 2012 to 2014 he came
into stranger things with a couple of TV
credits like most of his on-screen
friends but getting the part of Lucas
Sinclair and stranger things was the
hardest audition process he's been
through yet while his character Lucas is
the skeptic of the group in his
initially wary of Elle McLaughlin
revealed that off-camera the cast
clicked like magnets Noah snap-snap
originally auditioned for the role of
Mike wheeler but was equally excited to
learn he'd won the part of will Byers
when he got a phone call from the duffer
brothers while away at camp
snap made his film debut in Steven
Spielberg's 2015 movie bridge of spies
not a bad first gig for such a young
actor schnap went on to voice Charlie
Brown in the peanuts movie before
landing the part of will snap suspects
will won't quite be himself in the
second season the actor told The
Hollywood Reporter he thinks will is
going to become evil in season 2 and
seriously if barfing up slugs during
dinner doesn't make you evil what does
Nathalie dier dier stranger things
character Nancy wheeler starts out as
your typical 80s high school girl but by
the first season's end she's far from a
teen stereotype diving headfirst into
the upside down in search of her missing
friend barb
she told cosmopolitan it was really nice
to see a character like Nancy saying
quote she does have that love triangle
and boy drama aspect to her but she's
independent
and her main focus is about finding her
best friend in solving that mystery at
any cost
Joe Curie while steve harrington gets
under your skin at the start his change
of heart and obvious remorse come is
unexpected and somewhat refreshing and
even actor Joe Curie didn't see the
switcheroo coming the cast members were
given the scripts episode by episode and
had little idea about the fate of their
characters curie was certain he wouldn't
be around for the second season after
his questionable behavior early in the
storytelling marie claire' he was sure
he'd be monster food fortunately he
lived to the end of the season and even
became something of a cult favorite
among fans of that other popular show
set in Indiana
Parks and Recreation you guys have heard
about this fan theory they think that
Steve is actually jean-ralphio
real father Charlie Heaton when they're
not teaming up with Nancy to try and
rescue Will and barb from the upside
down Jonathan and Steve compete for her
affections and in very different ways
while Steve is the confident popular
type Jonathan admires Nancy from a
distance with his long lens camera
earning himself a reputation as a bit of
a creep their love triangle looks set to
continue in season two but even if
Jonathan isn't quite as prominent this
time around we'll still be seeing a lot
more of Heaton regardless the British
actor has been cast as the superhero
cannonball in Fox's upcoming x-men
spin-off New Mutants Shannon purser
let's finish things off with fan
favorites Shannon purser who looks
radically different when she's not
covered in a thick layer of pure 1980s
barb was a minor character and stranger
things who vanishes pretty early on
after being left alone outside by Nancy
while she hooks up with Steve and shows
up again at the end of the season when
her body is seen in the upside down an
unfortunate victim of the demo Gorgon
despite that Barbie came inexplicably
popular among stranger things fans the
justice for barb hashtag began trending
on Twitter after her character was
killed off and she became one of the
most popular Halloween costumes of 2016
and while Barb's fate seems pretty much
sealed at the end of season one some
dedicated fans still hold out hope that
she'll return for the follow-up
hey stranger things have happened
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]